these videos show the moment thousands
of riders charged through Brazil's
Congress
presidential Palace and Supreme Court
supporters of former president jair
bolsonaro smashed windows and ripped up
documents
the scenes reminiscent of the January
6th ride on the U.S Capitol came amid
protests over Brazil's election results
and days after the inauguration of Luis
Ignacio Lula de Silva in the lead-up to
the vote bolsonaro alleged election
fraud without evidence and he left the
country after the election
so as tensions rise between supporters
of the two main political factions in
Brazil
here are the key moments in the months
leading to the siege that can help us
understand how and why the chaos
unfolded
first let's rewind to late October
that's when leftist Luis enacio Lula de
Silva won the presidential election
runoff
the vote was the closest in the
country's history with de Silva taking
50.9 percent the vote to 49.1 percent
for bolsonaro
it was also a highly polarizing campaign
[Applause]
with voters on the left and on the right
divided over issues including economic
insecurity and Brazil's handling of the
pandemic now
do you want us
following the loss bolsonaro supporters
show their anger by camping outside
military Barracks calling for the Army
to remove the president-elect
in his first remarks following his
defeat bolsonaro thanked his supporters
and said he'd followed the country's
rules but he didn't concede and he
didn't congratulate to Silva toys
and the Same Day protests from his
supporters continued truck drivers
blocked roads across the country
rejecting bolsonaro's loss the crowds
only began to disperse after bolsonaro's
government confirmed the transition
toward a new Administration and asked
supporters to stop locating roads
located
but more unrest followed
when Da Silva's election victory was
certified by the federal court bolsonaro
supporters held a series of violent
protests in Brasilia
a bus was set on fire leading to arrest
at the end of December bolsonaro
encouraged his supporters quote not to
throw in the towel
on the same day the outgoing president
left his country and photos from Reuters
show that Brazil's equivalent of Air
Force One landed in Orlando Florida that
meant he was out of the country for da
Silva's inauguration ceremony in
Brasilia and when protesters targeted
Brazil's most important government
buildings
[Applause]
police in Brazil detained more than 1500
people accused of taking part in the
unrest and the Supreme Court removed
brasilia's Federal District Governor of
Baltimore Ally from his post after The
Siege bolsonaro condemned the ACT saying
that any vandalism or invasion of public
buildings was unacceptable
a day later he was briefly hospitalized
after complaining of stomach pains
related to injuries he suffered years
prior during a near fatal stabbing
that's according to his wife does Silva
visited Brasilia after the riots and his
supporters also took to the streets
the current president is also divisive
figure due to his role in a corruption
Scandal as well as for the Socialist
policies he put in place during his
first mandate he has promised to
investigate how the riots unfolded
president
thank you